[Music]
how would you react if you saw a video
online
of someone talking about a conversation
they overheard
of two people trying to uninvite their
friend with your name to their birthday
party
well that's exactly what happened to
marissa maize
and the way she responded was probably a
little different than most of us would
respond
instead of getting angry or lashing out
she went online and started her own
community of people who feel brushed
aside or just lonely
and they came together 200 of them to
meet in real life to foster new
friendships
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
marissa for those who don't know your
story
can you please tell us because it's kind
of
insane and wonderful all at the same
time
it is kind of an insane thing that
happened in my life i guess in a lot of
people's lives but
basically a guy named drew was walking
in madison square park and he overheard
two girls talking poorly about their
friend marissa saying how they wanted to
plan a party on a weekend that i would
be out of town so they wouldn't have to
invite me in the first place because
they already knew i was going to be out
of town
and he overheard it and i didn't know
drew by the way did not know who he was
never met him before we had no mutual
friends and he
posted a tick tock video he was saying
you know if your name is marissa and you
live in new york city and these are your
friends then i hope you find some new
friends and i saw the video it turned
around and got you know over 20 million
plus views i didn't even see the video
on tick tock i actually got it sent to
me about 50 plus times through every
platform of people either texting it to
me or messaging me and the last straw
was when my aunt actually sent it to me
who's in her 50s and was like this is
you and i was like how did you get this
video and where did this come from so i
watched the video and i was like this is
too detailed to not be me so me and drew
met up the next day
and
we talked about it it happened to be me
and from that turned into
a meet-up of some sorts because
overnight a lunch a bunch of people were
following me and messaging me saying hey
screw your old fake friends you know
let's be friends i would love to meet up
so i decided to have a mutual meet up so
let's back up a second here so you see
this video in tech talk
and you decide to turn this into
something
more magical which is to recognize that
there are other people out there who may
be experiencing similar things as you
which is to have these friendships that
we call friendships but are probably
more superficial than anything else
and you decide to create a space for all
of these people to come and meet each
other and so you post on social media
come to central park let's all meet up
and 200 people showed up and hung out
all day yeah we hung out for probably
about nine hours and then ended up after
the nine hours going to hang out
somewhere else at like a bar for a few
hours so and i hope some real
friendships were born out of that day in
fact how can they have not been
but the thing that i find really
fascinating about your story is not just
the story itself though the wonderful
which is it really raises the question
what is the definition of a friend in a
modern social media world i've talked to
young people before and they've said to
me
they are fully aware
that their friends would cancel on them
if better plans came up or
that they enjoy their friends they have
fun with their friends but they don't
really trust their friends it wouldn't
go to their friends if they were
struggling
and i find that
notion
kind of depressing because that sort of
is very different to what my notion of a
friend is so the question is has the
definition of friend changed
or
is there a young generation growing up
because of social media and cell phones
etc that are not enjoying the true
experience of what friendship means i
think it's a little bit of both to be
honest i mean i'm 24 i just from 24 a
little bit ago and i
did not find my quote-unquote
group of real friends until this started
which was kind of funny i feel like i
always was in that position that i
either
was maybe thinking that i wouldn't go to
them because i feel like they would tell
somebody else my my
secret or whatever was going on in my
life or whatever it was that i needed
help with and i feel that once this
whole thing started i finally found that
group of friends that
would be loyal back but also it's a
two-way street and they feel like
they're family to me and i could go with
them to anything and i feel like in
today's world a lot of people will
have these friends
and tell them something etc and then
this friend will go and turn around and
tell somebody else and be like oh look
what she came to me with or look what
problems she's having or this is so
embarrassing or something like that to
kind of dumb it down to other people and
i think that's the worst part of today
is that a lot of people don't find that
value in friends anymore and they don't
think that they're good enough for
better friends so they just trust these
people and then stick with them because
they don't have any other quote-unquote
options so you're saying even after the
trust is violated they still continue to
hang out with these people yeah because
a lot of people would rather be around
these people that will
stick around quote unquote or whatever
listen to them and rather than find
better friends because they don't want
to be alone my goodness but it's so
lonely being in friendships like that it
is that does not cure loneliness
so are you a better friend chooser now
what changed tell me what changed how
you choose friends now a lot has changed
in so many aspects i think
me being more confident in my
friendships me trusting people in the
right ways and also seeing things as a
two-way street i always reference that
because friendships are just like
relationships you have to care for each
other you have to do what's best for
each other and also if things aren't
working out you have to talk it through
i think that's how friendships thrive i
choose friends now that
help me as a person grow mentally and
physically and in life and also just do
better for both of us the thing that i
think is very significant here is that
your meetups are in person
yes are you better at talking on the
phone are you better at getting together
with people or are you back to sort of
dming and iaming and all the emmings uh
you know i do everything online but all
my meetups are in person and if i talk
to somebody online i eventually see them
in person or if they come to a meet-up
or whatever it is
i love
in-person interactions i think it's good
for
you i think it's good for me i think
it's good for everybody to meet up in
person because people think that they're
socializing and think they have so many
friends etc because they're talking to
these people online
and that's where
i think a lot of people get mixed up is
kind of they have this skewed reality of
oh my gosh i know her because i follow
her and we follow each other online we
talk online psychology has a term for
this it's called a parasocial
relationship
where it's one way
so it's like we're on first names with
brad and angelina for example right they
don't know who we are the parasocial
relationship is when we feel like we
know everything about somebody else
because we see them online and there's
intense pressure for people in the
public eye or for people who want to be
influencers to put themselves out there
and share their lives and what they're
eating and who they're dating and what
they're doing and so we feel like we
have a relationship with them like we
know them
when we don't what it is fundamentally
is a fake relationship
but it feels real to the person feeling
it that's the problem they really do
feel like you guys are friends even
though you've never met them what social
media has allowed for a
disproportionately higher number of
parasocial relationships and as you said
you exchange a dmr2 and it validates the
faux friendship
it takes effort to build friendships it
takes time and patience
and
vulnerability that horrible word right
yeah your generation is a pretty
activist generation which i love you
don't just complain about things you get
things done and what i love is that you
turn this
painful experience could have been
extremely humiliating because it was
done
out loud right so lots of people who
know you suspected that you might be
that marissa so it's also humiliating
because it was done publicly and yet you
turned this agony and pain into
something
very very positive which is you publicly
acknowledged it was you on tiktok and
then you
put out a call to anyone who feels that
their friendships may also not be that
deep to come make some real friendships
your lonely friends movement right yes
how did you come up with the name no
more lonely friends lonely friend is a
strange combination of words growing up
i was constantly around everybody i was
president of my school i was so sociable
i was friends with everybody but in the
end if i called somebody at night trying
to help no one would help me and i felt
so it was sad i felt lonely as a friend
you know and i
felt so weird that i had all these
clinical friends that never
acted like a friend
and i had some close friends sure but
i felt that there was more loneliness
than i felt like a friend and someone
said you know what do you want out of
this i was just like i just don't want
people to feel lonely anymore as a
friend i was like no more lonely friends
yeah like no more lonely friends and
someone said hashtag no more lonely
friends question mark like is this it
and i sat there and just contemplated
and in the end i was like whoa
no more lonely friends like that's it
like that's that's the line that's the
motto like turning strangers into
friends what was the last meetup you had
this last weekend was los angeles how
many people came probably about 400 wow
tell me one specific thing that happened
that made you smile and go it was worth
the trip it was a more special meetup
than others it was more eventy this time
we had a partnership with a few
different companies that came together
for an event we called new friendsgiving
thanksgiving is for family friendsgiving
is for friends new friendsgiving is for
strangers to turn to friends
i wanted to do something like this
because a lot of people are alone for
the holidays and that was something i
struggled with as well before especially
when i was living in la so a lot of
people came out to kind of meet people
so that they can spend the holidays with
and a special thing that stood out to me
was this one woman came up to me and
said
you know my wife has been really
struggling throughout the last few
months and i you know a lot of people
tell me that
and he said we just moved here a few
months ago and
she was regretting
thanksgiving coming up
and we have no family to spend here we
have no friends here we just moved here
we have no idea what we're doing and she
kind of was just
like i can't no thanksgiving doesn't
exist we're not going to celebrate it
whatever it is
he started tearing up and i was like oh
no this is when i start crying and he
said we have met so many people today
and that whole group right there sitting
with my wife there was about 12 of them
are all coming over because they were
all gonna be alone on thanksgiving and
now we're all spending thanksgiving
together
i mean it
makes me
just so
mind blown that my my little events that
i said hey meet up at this one spot at
this time and meet some friends sure or
whatever that that's gonna have a
lifelong impact on them forever you're
touching on such a basic human need
which is our desire to feel seen and
heard and to feel like we belong
that's where the insecurity comes from
in the first place which is i don't feel
like i belong
i love subcultures you know i love comic
con and all kinds of subcultures where
people who don't feel like they belong
find each other and i think loneliness
is one of those things where
you don't realize who feels lonely
people are good at putting on an act and
i think what you've done is you've made
loneliness not so lonely and to
recognize that if you put in a little
effort right like you go to this meetup
you'll meet people who kind of get you
and kind of understand because simply by
showing up you're telling everybody a
little bit about who you are just
because you showed up when i listen to
you and i listen to the work you're
doing i relate to it personally
and the internet is a blessing and a
curse right i wish the internet existed
when i was younger because i would have
found these communities a lot easier but
at the same time the internet
exaggerates so much of the thing that
makes us lonely and so it's a real
double-edged sword
and i think the trick to a lot of this
is putting the phone away do you require
that people put the phone away at these
things not necessarily but unless
somebody is exchanging information i
barely see people on their phones and i
think that's the coolest part is that
these people aren't having these
conversations of hey what do you do oh
my gosh i do this oh my god so cool it's
not those conversations it's like uh
nobody cares about what you do or who
you are it's like oh like
i came here for this you came here for
this like let's talk about life and one
of the partners for this this new
friendsgiving was this card game called
the deep it's a conversationalist game
where they give you prompts on the card
of very
deep like deeper conversations not who
are you what do you do it's what's the
most
vivid memory that your mother ever gave
you or something like that and it could
be a positive thing of let's talk about
this or it could be like
i don't want to talk about my family or
oh i can talk to you about my family
another way or whatever it is so it's
cool but it's these things that people
are so open to doing that
on a first date you wouldn't just sit
down at the table and be like so what's
your deepest darkest secret i had
somebody do that to me i went to a an
event
and it was like big long table we were
all eating at we're all strangers we're
all basically just met and this one guy
says hey so let's try and connect let's
all tell each other something we've
never told anybody before
and he says i'll go first and he goes on
to tell the story of how his sister
molested him when he was a child to a
bunch of strangers and then it's my turn
i'm like nope not playing this game with
any of you oh my god i don't know you
and i'm not telling you things that i've
never told anybody it's not going to
happen very often in our intense desire
to feel belonging and feel included we
script the timing brene brown talks
about this a lot vulnerability is not
meeting a bunch of strangers and telling
them your deepest darkest secrets people
misunderstand like we say you have to be
vulnerable but we don't mean right now
it's a dance it starts slow you know and
you pick up speed and i think that's one
of the things in our desperation to feel
included we're sometimes
grabbing and lurching out with these f
these strange
tactics that backfire all over the place
which only then makes us feel more
lonely there's going to be social
awkwardness i've i hang around socially
awkward people my whole life yeah you
know and so things like that can happen
at your meetup and what i like about it
is it's when you and i've been a part of
a group of you know creative socially
awkward people who all come together
[Laughter]
and it's magical because it's not a
networking event it's because to be a
networker it's a different personality
somebody who's like coming to get
something and it's a group of people who
know they need to put themselves out
there and this is a safe space they
found to put themselves out there
because they could go to other things
but those things are too
uncomfortable
is there someone you've personally met
at a meet-up who's touched you more than
someone else yeah there's uh two that
kind of go side by side that had
somewhat the same story but in the end
it turned out to be just something that
really kind of pushes me along
a lot of people ask me why i do it and
it's for these types of stories for sure
that hit me pretty hard and there was
these two people that they both had
severe autism it was the one girl's
birthday and she came to my meetup and
she said every year i've spent my
birthday alone and it made me want not
want to be alive and she said this was
her last year and she didn't think she
was going to make it and to her birthday
and if she did if she spent it alone one
more time she wouldn't she wouldn't have
continued
she said when i posted where i was going
and what date it was and she found out
it was her birthday that that was what
kept her there and made it to her
birthday because she was
at least happy to be around people and
she said she met so many people there
and this is the first year that she was
not alone and it literally kept her
alive
that really just i mean shot to the moon
of how i felt and how much of an impact
it could have on people and at the los
angeles meetup on saturday it was the
same thing he said i've never met people
that
didn't
look at me for my autism they just
straight up asked me what's your name
cool you want to come hang out with us
this saturday they didn't look at him
for who he was or whatever they looked
at him for how cool of a person he was
and how loyal of a friend he could be
what was your childhood like so my
parents divorced at a very very young
age it was a very very messy divorce
very messy childhood type of feel
so i think that
growing up i did a lot of
raising myself i was very involved in a
lot of things i liked doing sports i
like doing team things i like talking to
people and i always want to do like
public speaking etc
a lot of that rooted from i saw how
poorly people treated others and i
wanted to kind of
get my voice out there saying like stop
being mean to people and let's all be
friends like what's going on type of
thing so that's funny that this came out
of it because that was a huge thing i
liked in my childhood was that i was
friends with everybody who is the parent
figure in your life if it wasn't your
parents i looked to teachers at school i
had this one teacher mr carroll who was
my science teacher in in high school and
he was
kind of that that person for me in a in
a weird way that
really cared and also was just like
how's life how's this how's that and
would kind of go through the basics of
me of kind of seeing where i was at and
really broke it down into
showing he cared and showing that
meant a lot to me and and whatever it
was and i think he knew just that i was
looking for that type of person in my
life and he was there for me he treated
everyone with kindness and also made
sure that everyone you know whether it
was inside of the class or outside of
the class was heard and pushed empathy
that other people didn't give tell me an
early specific happy childhood memory
in eighth grade i made a my graduation
dress oh god this is embarrassing i made
my graduation dress out of capri sun
juice bags
and it was so happy for me because all
my friends helped me with gathering all
the capri sun juice bags from everybody
at lunch and everything that i got to
make this
thing that kind of showed my personality
and and everything
and also i was just really ecstatic to
make it i know that's like a weird
memory in a kind of
odd situation but that was something i
really enjoyed
i think it's a beautiful memory i think
it's about self-expression and if we go
back to mr carroll and the role he
played right
which is he saw you and heard you he
made you feel like you mattered and you
were going through these experiences as
a child you know about self-expression
and your friends helping you
self-express
and i think in some way shape or form
you've become mr carol
you've taken on the role where you're
gonna make sure that people know that
they matter that they feel seen and
heard with the hope that everyone will
you know wear their caprice undress with
the hope that everyone will be able to
express themselves as they truly want to
be as they truly are i mean quote you
again the people don't believe in you
for what you do but why you do it
that is one of i know it's an old an old
ted talk you did but it is one of
the most
relatable things in this situation
because people aren't coming to these
meetups because they're like oh she's
doing this and it's cool it's great it's
for why i do it because it's for others
it's not just for myself to gain friends
it's not for myself to gain money this
whole thing i pay for every meet up i
pay for my flights my hotels my ticket i
mean everything i'm losing so much more
money than i'm gaining and it's one of
those things that i'm putting this
effort and time and money into it
because people
see the value and people donate to it
they buy the shirts because they see the
you know they're like what can i do to
help can i volunteer in my city can i
host these meetups for you in my city so
you don't have to do as much because
they believe in it they see the value
and they see what's
going to be next and they're excited as
well with me so it's cool it's cool to
see people really enjoy and
and believe in it and back it
do you have any questions for me
what is one piece of advice you would
give to people that want to get
themselves out there but have a high
social anxiety
two thoughts come to mind
one is start online there are plenty of
online groups where there are people who
share a love of vermeer or whatever it
is you know love of something and
somebody can propose
why don't we all go out for dinner there
was a group that i was a part of a bunch
of years ago which is just a bunch of
creative misfits and literally like four
of us showed up at a bar
and we became very close friends very
fast and became a little community of
our own so i think starting online is
fine but there has to be the the
intention of actually meeting up at some
point
the other thing is go with a friend i
know it sounds awkward but you know will
you go with me is pretty powerful
and we don't build trust when we offer
help we build trust when we ask for help
giving someone the responsibility of
being there for you
makes them feel wanted and needed and
loved and it makes them feel trusted and
that their life has value i want to go
to comic-con
and didn't want to go alone because that
was way too awkward
and i called up one of my friends
and said will you go with me and it's
not her thing at all but she's like yeah
totally and she had a blast and i had a
blast and she had a blast because she
was just holding space for me that's a
true friend right there that's a true
friend so that's what i would recommend
i'd recommend starting online but with
the intention of going in person when
you all feel comfortable and then taking
a risk to go do something and asking a
friend to go with you that's amazing
marissa you're an inspiration and i wish
you nothing but good fortune and good
luck as your movement spreads it's
wonderful thank you so much i really uh
really do appreciate that
if you're interested in learning more
about marissa and her work you can
follow her on instagram at
marissamise or visit
nomorelonelyfriends.com
to find out any upcoming picnics that
might be happening in your area
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself
take care of each other